astronautinnen und astronauten haben
eine mission
sie forschen und machen experimente
sie senden coolen content aus dem orbit
zielgruppe junger menschen sie sind
rockstars in der wissenschaft
forschung social media tauglich matthias
maurer ist im netz astro matthias
deutschland derzeit höchster influenza
im dienste der wissenschaft
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr mein leben
hier oben verfolgen die den sozialen
medien
seine arbeitskleidung ein feuerfester
romans
der dienstwagen natürlich ein tesla von
ihnen masken
der look puristisch schwarz und weiß
matthias maurer unterschreibt an einer
recycelbaren raumkapsel der privaten
firma spacex auch von ihnen
[Musik]
eine neue generation von astronauten
startet in eine neue ära der raum
ein unglaublicher ausblick für sie live
aus der dragon kapsel zur erde
sie stellen ihr maskottchen vor eine
plüsch schildkröte namens v
spektakuläre bilder teilen gehört jetzt
auch zu ihrem
wir haben schon mal aus dem fenster
geguckt machen gerade erste fotos in das
zu trainieren bilder wie wird in
schweden sowie keller
sie fliegen ins all mit dem material von
ihnen muss milliardäre erobern den
weltraum fast schon normal
er war der erste privatmann der insel
abhob und noch ein paar leute mit namen
virgin galactic
[Musik]
ich war mal ein kind das sind die sterne
geschaut und geträumt hat jetzt bin ich
ein erwachsener in einem raumschiff mit
anderen wundervollen menschen und wir
schauen auf unsere schöne schöne erde
herunter an die nächste generation von
träumern wenn wir das hier schaffen
überlegt mal was ihr alles schaffen
wenn nun einer wirklich ins all gehört
dann doch eher captain kirk also mit dem
chef er war zehn minuten schwerelos dank
milliardär jeff bezos
[Applaus]
[Musik]
generationen sahen ihn in star trek
jetzt war er selbst oben tränen
champagner danke amazon
für die amerikanische weltraumbehörde
nasa ist diese konkurrenz praktisch sie
spart geld beim raketenbau und verdient
durch viele raketenstarts auf ihrem
gelände
die astronauten von heute müssen anders
denken sagte matthias maurer kurz vor
seinem start in kelz kinder kommt
kommerz und kosmos schließen sich längst
nicht mehr aus
also ich finde immer gut dass mehr
akteure aktiv werden mehr leute sich für
das thema weltraum interessieren weil
nur wenn mehr akteure oben aktiv sind
dann können wir natürlich auch die
systeme verbessern und dann auch die
systeme robuster machen und den zugang
für viele menschen ermöglichen auf die
lange frist gesehen denke ich dass
raumfahrt in der zukunft das sein wird
was heute die luftfahrt für uns ist und
wenn man 100 jahre zurückschauen dann
gab es weniger exoten die in klapprige
kisten gestiegen sind und dann durch die
lüfte geflogen sind heute ist es ganz
normal ich denke das ist auch die
zukunft der raumfahrt space coast nennt
man diesen küstenabschnitt in cape
canaveral raketen starten landen gebaut
werden
space shuttles vergangenheit diese
region floridas lebt von der neuen
modernen raubopfer die satelliten firma
web satellites produziert kleine
satelliten in serie sie werden ins all
katapultiert
damit es überall auf der welt schnelles
internet gibt
caroline ist 20 zukunftssorgen keine
unsere firma ist ja nur ein winziger
teil von dem angebot das der space coast
zu bieten hat es gibt inzwischen schon
mehrere firmen vertreten und serie
produzieren das ermöglicht eine sichere
karriere mit zukunft und wenn ich nicht
mehr mit satelliten arbeiten möchte
daneben mit raketen es gibt viele firmen
die raketen bauen für die elemente und
die unbemannte raumfahrt hier gibt es
einen riesige welt
das sieht auch amazon-chef jeff bezos
diese animation zeigt
seine raumstation
an bord sollen forscherinnen arbeiten
können firmen neue produkte entwickeln
touristinnen urlaub machen
lebensraum weltraum
zeitenwende im orbit
kasties fischrestaurant im hafen von
cape canaveral gab es schon bevor social
media erfunden wurde
er hat den erster amerikaner ins all
starten sie in cheb 1961 war das
für rusty steht auf dem bild darauf ist
er stolz
was die fischer ist auf seine art und
weise auch eine weltraum legende in cape
canaveral
in seinem restaurant hängen signierte
fotos autogramme alle astronauten und
kosmonauten haben sich bei ihr zum essen
getroffen und an den start von alan
shepard erinnert er sich ganz genommen
161 als alan shepard flug da ich auf der
highschool vor dem start haben wir alle
radio gehört sie sagten jetzt geht's los
dann sind wir alle raus und den staat
von seiner restaurantterrasse hat er
einen direkten blick auf den hafen
da das ist alles von elon musk
da landen die booster auf dem schwarzen
ding da hinten das ist neu
der raketenstart erst direkt da drüben
doch matthias maurer start verschiebt
sich schlechte wetterbedingungen ein
crewmitglied krank die space coast muss
warten
während breiter ist influenza agent und
musikproduzent aus frankfurt
er wird dieses boot mieten erst mal
fotos machen für alle follower
während breites mission laura auf der
iss social vermacht
eigentlich wollte er zum start eine
riesenschiff mieten dann kamen cupid
reisebeschränkungen startverschiebung
jetzt wird das alles mal eine nummer
kleiner angelegt
auch dass neben mir einfach so auf als
ein zeichen als ein wink vom universum
und fügen uns dem und machen trotzdem
jetzt unser boot und bringt trotzdem den
menschen die jetzt hier sind und den ich
das versprochen habe genau diese
eindrücke dass sie vor praktisch der
startrampe auf einem boot sitzen und
diesen feuerschweif sehen wenn die
rakete mit matthias maurer richtung
ausflug
dann gibt es auf dem kleinen kahn eine
weltpremiere
[Musik]
bernd hat die offizielle hymne zur
kosmix mission komponiert
und dieser trailer wirbt für ein
weltumspannendes
mega-event die esa hat das abgesegnet
[Musik]
maurer soll im all djs sein
ein menü zubereiten das die ganze welt
und nachkochen soll ziemlich abgefahren
aber davor darf man keine angst mehr
haben auf den endgeräten der influenza
des klicken licon tagen im dienste der
wissenschaft und des universums
was wir oben im weltall machen ist
prioritär wissenschaften das ist ganz
ganz wichtig aber die menschen haben
nicht so den direkten bezug zu dieser
technologie technologie zu dieser
wissenschaft und deswegen versuchen wir
moderne medien einzusetzen um das was
wir oben dann wichtigen dingen tun zu
kommunizieren um die menschen mit
einzubinden damit die menschen das auch
unterstützen und verstehen deswegen
haben wir viele events oben wir nutzen
soziale medien um den menschen auf dem
boden mitzuteilen wie fühlt man sich als
astronaut was macht ein astronaut wie
lebt man als mensch im weltall
die branche hofft mehr junge leute für
diese jobs zu gewinnen
fachkräftemangel gibt es auch in der
weltraumforschung es werden nachwuchs
und neue impulse gebraucht
erstens ist es nicht kommerz sondern es
wird das spricht eine andere sprache und
die leute der jungen leute an es liegt
mir sehr viel daran diese jungen leute
anzusprechen die ältere generation wie
auch meiner generation selber die wird
die haben wir natürlich andere
möglichkeiten das zu kommunizieren wir
verwenden natürlich beides und das wird
nach wie vor gemacht aber
klassischerweise war unsere
kommunikation sehr auf die mittlere bis
ältere generation ausgerichtet was
gefehlt hat war wirklich die jüngere
generation und da habe ich eine große
änderung gemacht in der iss hat gerade
durch social media aber auch die sprache
und die themen die wir ansprechen um
genau diese generation an
[Musik]
oben auf der iss wird der aufenthalt der
höchsten siege des universums
unfreiwillig verlängert
der franzose zum après ski ist zu einer
art rock star des weltalls geworden in
frankreich wird er als held verehrt auf
twitter und instagram erreicht er mit
rückflug verzögert macht nichts gibt
social media da kann man im all
gezüchtete peperoni spox
sie ziehen das durch
in oberthal im saarland gibt es eine
starke partie auch ohne statt
monatelang haben sie das hier geplant
kann man nicht mehr ab sagt
es ist schließlich ihr matthias
irgendwann wird er schon fliegen und das
kann man ja auch schon mal feiern
oberthal ist maurers vbs
um nichts in der welt hätte der
modellbauclub reisen diesen moment
müssen wollen staat oder nicht ihre
raketen müssen einfach mal der
öffentlichkeit gezeigt werden
heute sind über 2000 menschen in der
bliestal halle für ihren matthias der
erst mal am boden bleiben muss
dann haben wir gesagt jawohl wir feiern
trotzdem wir wollen unseren matthias ja
doch die ihre arbeit und ihr
kindheitstraum vom viele von meiner
generation von wo matthias seiner
generation und los diesmal ist stolz und
glücklich dass das fasten
und sie bekommen hier das letzte
interview mit dem astronauten vor seinem
abflug
eigentlich wollte ich um diese uhrzeit
schon die welt von oben sehen aber das
ist alles teil der raumfahrt dass man
sich an die bedingungen anpassen muss
sicherheit immer das wichtigste maurer
exklusiv das ist stoff von dem influenza
träumen diese hier haben einen klaren
heimat vorteil vielen dank für das
update live vom kennedy space center in
den usa und den matthias davon nutzen
das ist okay wir sind in der
raumfahrtbranche cool okay also julian
fühle ich mich jünger
ich wollte ich fragen was ihr macht in
eurer freizeit ob wir da oben
irgendwelche spieler habt oder was ihr
da macht was ich gerne mache ist
fotografieren und video video clips
auszeichnen weil ich möchte natürlich
dort oben in dieser umgebung wo ich bin
das ist so spannend so interessant und
und das war sich dort erfahren und
lernen das möchte ich natürlich den
meinen freunden und den menschen auf der
erde erklären wie man als astronaut der
irgend lebt wie man arbeitet und welche
tolle wissenschaft wir machen
ein paar tage später
splash daun im atlantik
in der kapsel der franzose thomas keye
er wollte matthias maurer oben treffen
ihm einiges zeigen fällt aus
dafür kann maurer jetzt endlich starten
[Musik]
elfter elfter drei uhr morgens
mitteleuropäischer zeit
während breiter ist an bord mit seinen
influenza aus deutschland und den usa
der astronaut social durch die decke
oberthal im saarland macht ein public
viewing raketenstart ihr matthias ist
endlich unterwegs
und auch houston meldet keine probe
cosmic ist kann ein bis los ist
[Musik]
das mit der kamera ist noch ausbaufähig
aber das geht schnell
twitter flickr facebook die welt weiß
wie astro matthias schläft wie er
trainiert
was es so zu essen gibt
welche experimente stattfinden
und da ist er der blick auf die erde und
eine videobotschaft gibt es auch
wie viele von euch habe ich nun einen
homeoffice denn meine neue wohnung in
columbus modul ist gleichzeitig auch
mein arbeitsplatz obwohl es da schon
einen unterschied gibt ich bin ich ja
nicht wirklich alleine und es ist
vielmehr eine home office wg meine
mitbewohner sind aber super und ich bin
stolz teil dieses tollen teams zu sein
was er sich da um schnallt ist ein ort
tauglicher vakuum sauger immer samstags
wird geputzt auf der iss aber an diesem
wochenende im dezember ist das nicht der
einzige termin für matthias maurer
unten auf der erde rückt bundespräsident
frank walter steinmeier ein gesteck
korrekt ins bild er wird live zur iss
schalten gemeinsam mit kindern aus
münchen und aus dem saal
diese kinder warten im weltraum atelier
nohfelden ganz in der nähe von matthias
maurers heimatdorf und dann ist er da
deutschlands astronaut an hilfen die
situation an ready for event
er erzählt wie es ist wenn man die welt
zum ersten mal von oben sieht
wenn ich an diesem moment zurückdenke
dann habe ich jetzt noch gänsehaut über
den ganzen körper das ist ein bild was
ich nur sehr sehr schwer beschreiben
kann weil es einfach so so so emotional
ist dass mir die worte fehlen und jedes
video jedes foto was ich bisher gesehen
habe beschreibt die sache eigentlich nur
mit fünf prozent alle diese kinder haben
seit ihrer geburt einen herzfehler
matthias maurer ist botschafter der
stiftung kinderherz erforscht dem all
nach lösungen für sie ich wollte sie
fragen ob durch ihre
forschung um all das ist ein fortschritt
für uns herz kinder auf der erde geben
könnte im bereich medizin haben wir
schon experimente laufen bei denen
herzzellen gezüchtet werden und diese
herzzellen die können hier in der
schwerelosigkeit wachsen die
menschlichen körper sie können sich in
einer 3d dimension wirklich so
entwickeln und wir hatten hier sogar
schon schlagende herzmuskelzellen das
ist jetzt alles noch grundlagenforschung
aber wenn man diese forschung weiter
betreibt dann kann es möglich sein dass
diese herzmuskeln vielleicht in zukunft
auch dazu dienen herzkranken kindern es
ermöglichen eine zweite eine normale
herzkammer dazu operiert zu bekommen
[Musik]
außenbordeinsatz
an der raumstation muss ein antennen
system überarbeitet werden
matthias maurer steuert aus der iss
einen roboterarm
für solche einsätze haben sie alle lange
unter wasser trainiert die bilder werden
von der nasa live übertragen später gibt
es sie auf youtube matthias baur
twittert natürlich
und er sendet klare botschaften auf die
erde da unten die von hier oben so
zerbrechlich wird teilen erwünscht sagt
den menschen dass es keine grenzen gibt
dass wir alle verantwortlich sind für
uns oder gemeinsame heimat und den
erhalt unseres kleinen planeten auch
wenn es den eingangs erwähnten langen
atem braucht so können wir doch
gemeinsam all dies schaffen für uns
selbst für alle erdenbürger und
natürlich für unsere kinder in der
zukunft jeder und jeder einzelne zählt
und ist wichtig es wird noch viele fotos
und videos geben von astro matthies
astronaut zwischen kommerz und kosmos
forschung wissenschaftler und influenza
im höchsten labor des universums